hey everyone this is Kevin from the test
website calm so they're going to be
looking at the belgrade game if you're
not too familiar with it starts out with
pawnee for pawnee v 9 f3 knight c6
Knight to c3 and the knight f6 giving in
to the four Knights game a lot of
variations the white can go from here
you could get into something crazy like
to have a wind gambit with knight takes
on e5 giving up that knife for a very
very strong attack we're going to be
looking at more than main line of pawn
to d4 after the pawn takes now matte up
here to d5 and as far as gambit skill on
the spectrum you have one end of kind of
a Halloween game but we're giving up
entire pieces like a knight for a very
very strong attack super fun to play and
then you have the other extreme the
Queen's Gambit where you're seeing it
the highest level the biggest
tournaments the the top players in the
world are playing that very very sound a
lot of theoretical chess going into that
this kind of falls in the middle I
wouldn't recommend it if you have a big
event or tournament that you're playing
especially if it's a longer game where
you have maybe two hours for time
control but if you're playing blitz if
you're playing for fun I think this is
completely fine you know fairly sound
for whites you're not going to get in
into crazy position you're like wow I'm
down three pieces why did I ever play
this it's definitely fun all in all I
think gamuts are a fun way to study the
game and if you do come across it's
always good to know how you should
proceed there's four main lines that I
see in this opening so that we're going
to be looking at the first one is Knight
takes on d5 the second one is the knight
takes on e4 and then you could also see
Bishop to e7 or what I see you know
fairly frequently is the knight down
here to be for attacking the knight here
on d5 it is being protected by the
bishop up here on f8 so the first line
we're going to look at is the knight
takes here on d5 and as you can imagine
the white pawn is going to immediately
recapture here on d5 now because it is
attacking the knight the Knights pretty
much going to have to move you could
have it in between move you know instead
of playing a knight down here to d4 or
east 7 he could decide to go ahead and
play Queen to e7 first check and then
you know there's the bishop here - II -
getting ready to castle on the Kings
side knowing that his pawn here on d4 is
not long for this world is going to end
up dying at some point because the
knights going to move no longer
protecting this and then either the
knight or the queen could take it he
could decide to go and just you know
sacrificial lamb here after the pawn
takes this does block off you know this
development from the lights where Bishop
which is how black may proceed and then
Knight down here to b4 castle on the
Kings side but all in all White's going
to have you know a very good game he's
still kind of blocking off his bishops
here Queen on e7 is not doing anything
right now you can just swing over here
rook to e1 starts to put pressure after
the bishop moves on the Queen it's going
to be chasing it around this night here
on before is not doing a ton could
capture the material up here on d5 but
all in all I think is completely fine
for white you may not see the Queen come
up here to e7 I just like to cover just
to make sure that if you do see it now
we're going to be looking at the knight
to be for an e7 look at E 754 gets the
material back that you lost you have a
very strong attack with you know the
pawn in the center of the board both
sides kind of have the same pawn
structure going into the endgame but
White has a very easy way to get his
light square Bishop and his dark squared
Bishop involved into the game black on
the other side both of these bishops
have very very difficult to get involved
into the game so all in all white
definitely has a good game from here I
actually prefer a different route
because I like to give my opponents more
opportunities to make mistakes and so I
prefer pawn up here to b6 and sometimes
when you attack an opponent's minor
piece like this they decide to go ahead
and move that minor piece so let's just
hey let's swing it back here to c6 you
know if he takes my pawn here on c7 I'll
just read taketh my queen that's going
to be fine but that's not what we're up
to here we're actually going to be
looking for Queen to e2 check and since
his King can't move he's going to end up
losing material because of our pawns he
can bring his knight back if he wants to
block there's Bishop it doesn't matter
we're going to take with our pond he's
going to go down in material that's kind
of the play
here especially if your opponent hasn't
seen this game bit some of these tricks
may work on them now if they say you
know what I'm not going to do that I'm
going to take with my pawn that's fine
too
the night's going to recapture and if we
kind of look at this yes black is up a
pawn in material but as far as the
structure on board I'm going to take
White's position all day long kind of
open up the center of the board for both
the bishops to get very very involved
into the game he has the most central
minor piece with a night here on d4 he
has the better pawn structure getting
into the in game you know double pawns
here on the D file and then kind of
three sets just not as good getting into
the endgame
it's going to be very difficult for
black to continue here how does he get
his light square bishop or even his dark
square bishop which is very blocked off
how did you castle on the Kings side he
just doesn't have a lot of good
prospects as far as how he continues
let's go over a few options if he were
to play pawn to b6 maybe he wants to get
his lights for a bishop involvement of
the game a wife could play Bishop to c4
starting to attack the weekend
f7 square right here knowing that okay
if you're going to you're going to focus
on the Queen side you're definitely not
trying to protect your king over here on
the King side so maybe maybe now Knight
to c6 getting ready to play Bishop e7
castle on the Kings side maybe it's a
move too late right now because you
could just play castle on the King side
here getting ready to bring your rook
over here to e1 if he takes the knight
on d4 it's just all sorts of bad because
that just gets another valuable piece
involved into the game with Queen takes
on d4 and now Bishop to e7 that just
loses to Queen to g7 attacking the rook
right here rook comes over here to f8
it's very difficult you can just have
look to a 1 then Bishop here to g5 so
lots of differing attacking lines that
we have on board now say instead of the
bishop coming to e7 we see Queen to f6
well now we just say Queen to e4 check
and then if we see Bishop to e7 then the
rook here on a 8 is going to false
another attack that we had and we come
back and say let's not bring Queens f6
we're not even going to worry about the
keen side of the board let's go to a
bishop to b7 that was our plan all along
now rook to e1 is very difficult to deal
with
check this kind of if the Queen comes
the e7 is going to lose his queen if he
brings his bishop here to e7
then we're talked about it clean up here
to g7 if he plays rook to f8 Bishop up
here to h6 and you can see this is going
to be extremely bad now if we were to
come back on board you know quite a ways
back and say you know how do we approach
this if instead of the pawn to b6 what
if it was just Knight to c6 well there's
kind of two options here you have one
that let's just get to the endgame and I
like my pawn structure better so we'll
kind of go with that and that option
looks like this it's it's Knight to b5
getting ready to attack this career here
on d6 and there's not a lot of great
wary ways for a black to hold on to this
so we could just play pawn to a6 and
then we take here on d6 we recapture a
little bit and you could even decide you
know I'll go in exchange my queens off
the board and from here White's going to
be completely fine he still has the
double Bishop parry has a better pawn
structure so if you're looking to get to
the in game quickly you can go this
route if you're not looking to do that
maybe you think you're about stronger
player and so you want to have more
material on board instead of playing
that night to b5 you could just play
punt up here to c3 still allows yourself
to get your Queen involvement of the
game if you want to somewhere else
you can get both of your Bishop still
involved into the game if you were to
take you can just recapture with your
queen very aggressive Queen on board he
still has that double pawn structure on
the default so you're gonna have a lot
of good games here so that's what
happens if you were to try to play that
Knight to c6 depending where else you
know he goes he just doesn't have tons
of great options so you can really
attack depending on where he decides to
go so we come back to this position say
well 97 is not the best move I agree
it's definitely not the best move if you
were to play something like a knight to
to be four here's kind of my approach
sometimes you may see Bishop to c4
recommended
that's not really my jam so I'm looking
to do here after Queen to e7 am I really
going to bring my bishop back here to e2
and then let him push forward with pawn
to d3 or am I really going to be playing
King to f1 no I'm not going to do that
so I don't like the Bishop to c4 it does
protect my pawn but at this stage I'm
okay giving up that pond so I don't have
to deal with initiating it that blocks
up too
instead I kind of go for just pawn to a3
and then after he takes that's fine I'll
go ahead and take with with my queen
attacking his knife he wants come back
to f6
I can play Bishop up here to g5 maybe
Bishop e7 and then hey it's go time
let's catch on the Queen side I kind of
know you're going to be casting on the
King side and there's just an all-out
attack which is why I play a game bit in
the first place if you were to come back
and instead play instead of playing
Knight to f6 maybe Queen to e7 now I'm
okay with playing the bishop you -
because I didn't move it to c4 I didn't
waste a move coming back here to e2 i
can cast on the King side a little bit
later this is going to be a fine game
for me don't make the mistake though
instead of that pawn to 8 a 3 don't
think you can come up here to d4 that's
a bad life decision nice to see - check
you're going to lose your queen so just
take the safe route just play pawn to e3
give up that pawn you're going to be
completely fine and have a good game the
next variation we're gonna look at is
the knight takes here on e4 now there's
kind of two options you have the queen -
E - that's pinning down the knight but I
think this just gets a little awkward
ask - pawn to f5 I can't like this from
black you know this is a nice little
outpost for the Knights and this Queen
is kind of blocking off my light square
bishop I love getting my light square
Bishop involved in this particular
opening because the King side of black
is always weakened and so if I can get
that in a very critical Square like
Bishop to c4 and really attack the Kings
side of the board thing that's really
good this stops me from doing that so I
don't like playing Queen to you to which
you may see in
places and said I like a bishop here to
d3 this attacks the knight it also
allows me to later on play Queen to e2
if I want to so there's a few ways that
black can can stop this one of those we
kind of looked at if he plays pawn to f5
and here's the approach if he does that
take the knight right away he's going to
1% of the time take back with his pawn
and you're going to castle on the King
side kind of baiting him to go ahead and
take your knight right here but if he
does it's going to be a mistake
pawn takes here on f3 and you're just
going to be playing a rook over here to
e 1 very very difficult for him to kind
of stop this we've looked at this
briefly because the Bishop to g5 because
that's such a strong attack I'll tell
look at a few options if he plays Knight
to e7 try to stop it Bishop up here to
g5 this nice being pinned down to the
King from the rook and it's also being
pinned down by the bishop to the Queen
right here so you know if he what does
he do now I can't move the knight if he
plays pawn to c6 trying to break up our
Knight right here that's fine just go
ahead and take with our Knight there's a
discovered attack so you know he kind of
needs to take it if we take he takes
then the Queen is going to fall there's
no square that he can go to where we
can't just have a discovered attack
Bishop here to c5 you can see check he's
going to end up losing that clean so
he's pretty much just going to have to
play clean takes rook up here after the
King takes in clean up here to d4 this
should be a very very easy in game for
white to go to if instead of the knight
coming here to e7 he could decide to
play Bishop to e7 same kind of thing
Bishop to g5 maybe in this particular
case he can castle on the King side
that's one nuance it's a little bit
different but now you could just take
with your knight if you want to maybe
Knight taste now the route can come up
here to e7 and then you know punt up
here to d5 opening up the door for the
light square bishop but then work over
here to g7 check after the king takes
bishop takes on d8 do lose some material
you
but still have that Queen on board and
the Queen going into the in game
especially when the board state is very
open you can really attack your opponent
as Kings put a lot of pressure on any
other piece on the board with a check
and attacking that it's going to be very
difficult for black to kind of hold onto
here so that's kind of what it looks
like if they just take that piece right
here on f3 which we kind of know is a
mistake if for some reason he says you
know what I'm not even going to worry
about this right now I'm instead going
to play keen to f7 well we kind of
concede that's a huge mistake with Queen
to f3 that's not even trying to be safe
this King just going to be on our attack
for the rest of the game that's going to
be very very bad so if instead of f5 we
kind of looked at that and said that
that's fairly good for white I'm okay if
he plays upon to f5 in this position he
could decide to go to move his knight
could play Knight to f6 and then we have
the Queen to e2 as we talked about if he
wants to block it that's fine we'd go
ahead and take with our knight right
here you can't take it back with his
Bishop because it is being pinned down
so when he recaptures it does have a
weakened king side we can pawn structure
he has two double pawns on the DMF I'll
I'm completely fine as white going into
the endgame in this position if instead
of Knight to f6 maybe he decides to go
and bring it over to the Queen side of
the board maybe Knight to c5 this is
probably a little bit better from black
and so I played castle on the King side
and said that Queen to e2 because now
the knight can come back here to e6 even
if you were to side to play Bishop to e7
first and then Knight to e7 or eise Ickx
this does block off more and so i don't
know that the the Queen here on e 2 is
really doing what I wanted to so instead
I'll I'd rather just castle on the King
side if he plays Bishop here to e7 then
you could just swing over here rook to
e1 if you wanted to or if you really
just want to get his Bishop pair off the
board you could go ahead and take here
on e7 as well you have some options the
next option that we'll look at is Bishop
here to e7 kind of a safe move it
immediately says I'm not sure what
you're doing with this gambit but I want
to castle on the King side as fast as
possible to get some safety I'm kind of
up upon a material so I don't want to do
anything too crazy and you have a few
options here I kind of have what I
consider the bailout plane which is a
man I wish you hadn't played these seven
let's just go ahead and exchange that
your off on board and I can have a good
end game and we'll be okay with that and
that plan usually looks like this Knight
takes on d4 Knight takes on a d5 we see
some exchange on board all of a sudden
Queen up here to d4 and you're good both
sides equal and material you both have a
double bishop pair no sides really that
much better off I mean an active queen
in the center but that's pretty much it
he doesn't necessarily have to go along
with all your plans
you know after you decide to go ahead
and you know take with you plays Bishop
here to e7 and you decide to go ahead
and take he could decide to play
something crazy you know Knight takes on
e4 but if you boys 94 here here's kind
of how I like to approach it with
Knights to be 5 this is having both your
Knights attack here on c7 which would
fork the rook here on a eight that would
definitely be a win but from here you
could see castle on the King side and
then you could play Bishop up here to d3
forcing the Knights move if you tried to
play that you know pawn to f5 we've kind
of seen that before
castle on the King side this is going to
be good for white if he instead decides
to just bring his knight back here to f6
then yeah let's go ahead and start
taking material he could decide to go
ahead and play Knight takes here we
should Knight comes back here this is
going to be fine for white you can now
castle on the King side so you kind of
have your bailout plan if he doesn't go
along with your plan you still have a
nice backup here I like a different
approach I don't necessarily like to
just go with the bailout plan because I
don't mind if you play Bishop to e7
early on so if he does decide to go and
play Bishop e7
I'm more of the Bishop to f4 I like to
be pretty aggressive on board get more
of the bishops involved into the
material if you're going to play similar
passion
this should be seven castle on the
kingside I'm going to develop as much
material as possible now if you move
City does have a plays Bishop to b4 I'm
fine with this he's moved his Bishop
twice that's not really what I would
recommend I would go ahead and take my
Knights or with my night if you
recaptures that's fine now we play that
same pawn to a3 that we saw earlier now
may be nice to see six push our pawn up
to e5 forcing the night here on f6 to
move and we can get our light square
bishop welcome to the game more than
likely here to c5 or c4 starting to put
more pressure on our opponents King side
and he hasn't even captured yet even
though this was kind of a game plan
early on with that Bishop to e7 he
hasn't done this now B the sides okay I
brought my bishop here to e7 not so I
can move it again
if you decided to go ahead and take our
night here on d5 that's fine we can just
recapture if we wants to maybe now
Knight down here to b4 but then that
pawn to d6 move we saw this earlier in
some variations this is still a very
very strong attack that we have on board
so I like to go ahead and point that out
like that d6 move or if he decides you
know instead of any of that a good play
just pawn to d6 great we can just go
ahead and take that material here on d4
gain that material back we have a very
strong presence in the center we can get
our LightSquared Bishop involvement to
the game castle on the King side all in
all these variations we've looked at it
no point has black really put us in a
bind we're like wow I hope he doesn't
play this because then we're in a really
bad spot which is really nice I like a
gambit that allows my opponent to make
mistakes but at the end of the day if he
plays optimally I'm still in a decent
spot now the last variation that we're
going to be looking at into the Bishop
to e7 he could play bit or Knight down
here to b4 and I have been seeing this
you know more and more and you have kind
of two options one is what I like to
call fight for the d4 square and so it
looks like this you could go ahead and
take care on f6 if you want to he could
recapture then pawn here to a3 night
comes back here to c6 a lot of these are
somewhat forced Bishop here to c4
Bishop to c5 you can see a lot of
pressure being put on this d4 square we
could try to kick this back so pun up
here to b4
come back get our darker beige involved
in the game also attacking the pawn here
and this area of the forward castle on
the Kings side you can see blacks going
to be up upon a material and both sides
are just fighting for the square so that
is a fight if you want to do that if
instead you decide that's not really the
path that I want to go you also have the
option after the the knight comes down
here to be four of just playing Bishop
up here to c4 I think this is completely
fine it's kind of a coin toss in my head
that I would make as far as which one I
would choose to do do keep in mind
though if they take with either of the
knight doesn't matter if they take it
with their be nice or if they're going
to be taking it with their f Knight
recapture with your pawn don't recapture
with your bishop this is going to play
extremely well it's going to allow you
to castle on the King side get your work
over here to e1 then later on if you
wanted to play that pawn to d6 you do
have some oxygens with that also you
know get that dark square Bishop Bolton
to the game with the pawn here that's
going to be a very very strong attack so
I really like that also make sure that
you know your opponent doesn't recapture
if you if your bishops here he can
recapture with this Knight you want to
hold on to that double Bishop pair in
this opening so that's kind of a
introduction to the Belgrade gambit as
many of you have requested from me this
particular gambit if you have other
openings that you would like to see me
cover feel free to email me at the chest
websites at gmail but hopefully you guys
enjoyed try it out and let me know what
you guys think and I'll see you guys in
the next video thanks for watching